à la santé d'Antoine Blondin plusieurs
dizaines de concurrents ont participé
cet après-midi à Saint-Germain des prê
au 6e marathon des leveurs de coude 42
étapes dans 42 bistr à chaque étape un
demi Tastevin de de beaujolet l'écrivain
Antoine Blondin décédé l'an dernier
faisait partie des initiateurs de cette
manifestation à suivre mais seulement à
suivre sans
modération c'est la convivialité c'est
Saint-Germain des pr c'est le beaujolis
c'est c'est la joie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vivre parmi les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tiens
combien de ver ah là on est au 3e c'est
calme c'est cool encore et au bout du
42e ça se passe comment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien écoutez il en France on a le goû de
la fête et le romantisme de